[Applause]
leadership is called the actions of
Donald Trump reprehensible in a huge
amount of tear gas was being used it's
like dropping there's an experience like
drowning I have determined that it is
time to officially recognize Jerusalem
as the capital of Israel it's a
dangerous thing to play around with the
whole notion about how on earth you
sought this conflict out has been that
Jerusalem East Jerusalem would be a
capital of a Palestinian state that
certainly had a Palestinian seer but
then of course it is obvious Israel
believes that Jerusalem is its capital
the Prime Minister is based here the
Israeli Parliament is based here so in
that sense it could argue as the
Israelis do it's not particularly
controversial it's just recognizing what
is actually a fact Israel has placed its
capital here and as a consequence they
would say that Trump is just stating the
obvious
[Music]
we knew that it was coming and as soon
as it did obviously you know emotions
changed the mood changed here quite
dramatically we all knew that make
everything is worse than before because
you know Jerusalem is the redline what
that decision on Jerusalem did was
really turned the Palestinians against
Trump and against his policies to
it's a touchstone to everybody here and
it's inflammatory this is a city that is
on edge most of the time
and all it needs is for something like
that to happen it's like lighting a fuse
it can ignite
[Applause]
[Music]
people have fought over Jerusalem for
hundreds and hundreds of years the fact
probably remains that they will continue
to do so as long as there is religion in
this world
[Music]
so it is from that dimension
controversial
and the process that followed abouts not
surprising as a result
I think amongst the journalists and
amongst us our team who are covering it
there was probably a sense of
expectation the thing that really struck
you was just how sort of noisy and how
lively it was people were chanting you
know sort of though the chance that
we've heard for so many years not just
in in Palestine but across the Middle
East that you know with our soul and our
blood will protect or defend you
Jerusalem a lot of anger even even even
my kids ages 14 and 15 they didn't like
it they were so angry
everybody old young this is like
touching that the holy book like
touching the the most holy place
[Music]
suddenly hey where's our capital we want
that East Jerusalem as the capital
that's now off the table
so where do our negotiations go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you were starting to see process
[Music]
protesting Gaza protests all over the
West Bank
and processes in East Jerusalem as well
and it was chaotic
and the big question when you're seeing
those process on the street is is this
going to turn into something much bigger
a huge Palestinian uprising a backlash
against this decision it will get bigger
you think yeah there will be more of
this yes yes so what will happen next
tell me tell me what you think will
happen next keep keep going do this
thing
I think the verdict is still out on that
the political leadership of the
Palestinians has really no legitimacy on
the Palestinian streets so where does it
go from here you have a very young
population of Palestinians who have
known nothing other than the occupation
when it flares up it's usually in the
same areas
I think the first major protest we did
were just outside Ramallah the capital
of the Palestinian Authority is where
their sort of leadership sits and it was
you know certainly bigger demonstrations
than I've seen since I've been based
here the level of anger was intense
a mixture really of hopelessness
frustration and of course that was
directed at their checkpoints which are
not just checkpoints for Palestinians
they are symbols of the occupation
symbols of what they experienced from
their points of view and oppression on a
daily level the battlegrounds that air
so to speak seem to be quite well drawn
out from previous process stones being
thrown and then Israelis responding with
rubber bullets live ammunition in some
cases and tear gas huge amounts of T has
to try and suppressing and quell the
anger of the Palestinian people so on
that day in particular we sort of
positioned ourselves a bit further down
the road somewhere we were you and your
team of thief as soon as you're actually
getting ready for for any any conflict
environment whether it's self warzone or
riot or a protest the mood instantly
changes when you put your flak jacket on
that's the moment that your brain sort
of kicks into gear and you
subconsciously sort of feel an extra
sort of level of angst so you have to
protect yourself protect your team
a lot of the time it comes down to
experience it's not necessarily my
experience spurts and smear on the
ground tea has been here for its entire
life it's really just making sure that
you have enough cover around you live
ammunition is use rubber bullets are use
stuff that can seriously hurt you or
kill you fear is a very important part
of it you know a if you didn't have that
emotion that's that defense system to
depend on most of the time it's it's
tear gas and your drug bullet the robber
bullets can kill history has proven that
journalists have died in this country
when they weren't expecting it when they
thought they were safe Palestinian
leadership is called the actions of
Donald Trump reprehensible it says that
the Americans have abandoned all
neutrality it's dangerous for a
cameraman because he's looking through
the viewfinder it's quite easy to just
shut down everything else just
disappears and you're only focusing on
what you're looking at here we have
Samir he's always watching our backs so
you are his eyes so you have to watch
everything I let him know what's
happening
a huge amount of tear gas was being used
this would've fired in arcs there's no
science to it it's an art of where it's
going to drop so there's one goes long
one short and then you're trapped in the
middle and the idea is you leave the
space so if you've missed time that as
IDs you get caught in this massive cloud
of tear gas and it's profoundly
unpleasant experience you feel you're
dying you can't breathe it's it's it's
difficult to explain if you don't
experience that you feel as though you
you're suffocate it's like drowning it's
an experience like drowning it always
reminds you of the huge asymmetry
between the positions of the
Palestinians and the Israelis one is a
truly modern army a modern state and on
the other side you have kids throwing
stones
using slingshots to hurl at the soldiers
most of the stones landing landing
Shores
the images expose are very powerful just
because of the asymmetry
[Music]
the occupation has been going on since
sort of certainly of the West Bank since
1967 so it's 50 years they are very used
to dealing with the protests it's it's
something that they are well accustomed
to doing what Palestinians say is that
Donald Trump took Jerusalem off the
table there is now no table to sit at
he's not just taking it off the table
he's taken away the table
[Music]
Palestinian been talking about peace for
like two decades and by taking Jerusalem
out from from the deal it's been all
collapsed
[Music]
they would never regard I think the US
as an honest broker they never really
have but they always had I think maybe
an expectation or a hope that there were
certain red lines that wouldn't be
crossed when it came to the conflict to
the crisis between Israelis and
Palestinians and that Jerusalem the
status of Jerusalem was one of those red
lines
[Music]
now they believe that Trump and the
people around him are actually part of
the problem as well you're now hearing
Palestinians say yes the Americans can
be part of a mediation process but not
on their own not with the Israelis
because the two of them you can't get a
cigarette paper between them they are
the same the most straightforward red
lines which you believe will never be
crossed are crossed are ignored and are
essentially no longer part of the
process no longer part of the discussion
I think that's a genuinely devastating
and worrying situation for many
Palestinians to face people need talk
and and you're taking the last hope like
to have the capital there is a sense of
futility I think all people here
experience
you're very much less banging your head
against a brick wall that things if they
are changing the difference is
imperceptible in fact at the moment it
seems like things may be going backwards
there is a sense that you know things
will still be the same as they are now
in 10 years and 20 years I think on the
Israeli side nobody expects really any
movement on on this I knew here Israelis
say there is no partner for peace
that's the Israeli narrative on the
Palestinian side no I think they've lost
faith in their own leadership and I
think that they they don't see a
two-state solution materializing I think
people have lost hope